[Music]
if you like DIY then you'll know how
satisfying is to fix something that's
broken if you want a bit of inspiration
we've got some great examples of
makeovers make sure to watch this video
to the end and see how you can fix a
broken cellphone and make it beautiful
if this is your first time you've
visited our channel don't forget to
subscribe and give this video a big
thumbs up today we're looking at 15
genius people who fix broken stuff
instead of throwing it away
DVDs fix a birdbath when one wildlife
lover bought herself a brand new
birdbath she thought she would be able
to attract lots of feathered friends
with her new purchase unfortunately the
bass fell down and broke rather than
throw it out she had a genius idea
she found a load of DVDs that she didn't
want anymore and discovered that if he
pulled them apart you can cut the shiny
side into pieces she did so replicating
the mosaic effect in the original bulb
using grouting to help protect the birds
feet and the new colors
she made a bath that changes color
depending on which angle you look at it
from the new piece could be considered
an improvement on the original sure the
birdbath this woman bought was practical
and attractive but the repaired version
seems more colorful and is definitely
more unusual who knew those old computer
DVDs could be so useful hey guys we are
so excited to announce we are producing
our own original content head over to
the trendy for the best DIYs fashion
tips makeup hacks and so much more we
are sure you're going to love it and be
sure to let us know
in the comment section he left me here
from you see you there see-through
material repairs wooden chairs there's
something a bit special about
old-fashioned wooden furniture whether
it's something that reminds us of days
gone by or whether it's something that
gives a room a real retro feel some
people wouldn't get anything but but
what happens when it breaks you'd think
he wouldn't be able to save a wooden
chair that had bits missing right but
artists
pétain Freitas does something out of
this world rather than throw the
furniture away or else try to fix it
with bits of wood that don't quite fit
right she uses see-through acrylic to
repair things the end result is stunning
like a chair with bits missing that
actually ends up working absolutely
perfectly and looks like a wonderful
piece of art at the same time too tans
work has been exhibited all over the
world although we'd hope people who saw
her pieces got the ideas to fix their
old furniture to hold becomes artwork
one of the worst things you can do in
your home can be making a hole in the
wall
if you rinse there's a good chance your
landlord will take the cost of fixing it
from your deposit well if you own your
home it'll cost a lot of money to repair
it but what if you saw the opportunity
to create your own worth of ours that's
what one person did when her boyfriend
fell down the stairs one Thanksgiving
rather than spend the time and effort
trying to get the wall where he put his
hand through back to pristine condition
she had another better idea using a
stylish black picture frame she
surrounded the hole and put up a plaque
saying first Thanksgiving 2015 medium
hand drywall just think about it it
turns what could be a pretty nasty
defect in your home into an absolutely
awesome work of art broken flower pot
becomes miniature garden gardeners know
that a key part of making a garden look
pretty is the humble flowerpot but what
happens when one of them breaks pretty
cheap to replace so you just throw it
out and get a new one right but one
green-fingered wizard had just the right
idea for reusing them she washed them
and placed the bits that had fallen off
inside the shell of the old pot and
stuck them together then the real magic
started
happen she used different types of soil
to create a rain to players that could
sustain a variety of different plants
after that she got a ladder from an old
dolls house and set them up between the
different layers where the little plants
would blossom to create an appearance of
a beautiful miniature fairy garden so if
you find that bad weather is causing
your flowerpots to break don't despair
because you can have a lovely new little
garden lace dollies save a couch cat
owners love their pets so much they
bring so much joy into people's lives
but one of the risks of having a cat is
their fondness for scratching furniture
let's face it couches are very expensive
but if your kitty claws end up at one it
can rip the fabric and leave the feeling
exposed which in turn makes your living
room look bad so how do you solve the
problem what one ingenious person did
seem simple but super effective they
bought some lace dollies and dyed them
to match the fabric of the damaged sofa
then they carefully sewed them into
place meaning their old sofa looks even
better than it did before
the studies claimed appearance was
transformed into something way more
intricate and pretty and it didn't cost
too much either so you don't have to
choose between your beloved cat and your
nice stylish furniture anymore turtle
power saves a wall fans of the iconic
90s TV smash it kids cartoon Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles will remember the
heroes in a half-shell climbing out of
the New York sewers to battle with the
evil shredder his goons bebop and
rocksteady and his boss Krang however
one smart person got them climbing out
of his wall and fixed up an unsightly
hole in the process this guy saved the
wall which had been busted up by water
damage by putting in toys of leonardo
Donatello Raphael and Michelangelo
climbing out of the gap in doing so he
managed to turn something that would
have otherwise looked really bad into an
awesome feature for his home Cowabunga
dude seriously this guy's idea is
fantastic we wonder which classic TV
characters would you use to fix a wall
and who is your favorite turtle you can
tell us in the comments below
fix holes and jeans for the
pache perhaps the single most ubiquitous
item of clothing today is the pair of
jeans think about it you've probably got
a pair and pretty much everyone you know
does too so we all know that sometimes
denim a pretty sturdy kind of fabric can
wear out especially at the knees now you
might want to keep your jeans with a
hole in them so you can have an
old-school grunge rocker look and that's
awesome but what if you want to fix the
hole one woman came up with a look that
blew our minds her partner's jeans had a
hole in the knee so she turned the gap
into a monster's mouth to use corduroy
and felts to create it turning an old
pair of jeans into an awesome cartoony
and unique new pair let's be honest we
think we'd all ask the guy where he got
his fantastic jeans from if we saw him
wearing them give a cracked mirror a
border the old superstition says that
you get seven years bad luck if you
break a mirror and it's certainly a
massive inconvenience you have to make
sure that the place where you broken is
clear a broken glass before you throw it
out and buy yourself a brand new one but
what if you could fix it that'd be
pretty cool and the great news is you
don't have to be a professional glazier
to do it one woman did exactly that when
she bought a mirror that had a crack in
it she used her smarts to find herself
some little tiles that could cover up
the damage and using some silicon
adhesive
she gave her new mirror a special and
unique makeover that made it stand out
from the crowd
we wonder though how could she focus on
her reflection when she managed to fix
herself up such a special piece of art
save jumpers with Koch's anyone who has
some nice woollen items of clothing can
tell you two things firstly how
wonderfully warm comfy and stylish they
are and secondly the dangers posed to
them by moths those little critters are
able to eat large holes in them turning
your lovely old jumper into what looks
like it could just be a horrible mess
and the holes can't really be darned
properly so you have to throw them out
that is unless you're one very smart
lady who counteracted the insect damage
with a whole new style she got herself
some pattern material from an old item
of clothing I
cut it up into the shape of a bird and
sewed it on this meant she didn't have
to get rid of the sweater and indeed
made it look cooler and more interesting
than before but you don't have to use a
bird shape why not tell us what shape
you'd use to hide the moth holes make a
chair as good as new with belts if
you're setting up a home of your own for
the first time there's a good chance
you'll want to make every penny count so
what to do if you've got what would be a
stylish and useful chair only the pit
that you sit on is broken for one young
couple in Florida the answer was
stunningly simple and meant some old
bits of furniture didn't have to be
thrown away a family member had some
chairs with the seats missing so they
took hold of those and hid thrift shops
to buy as many old belts as they could
find then they'd stretch the belt across
the chairs tighten them up and screw
them in it took the two a long time but
when they were done they had some
awesome and unique chairs here's a tip
if you want to do what they did make
sure you're careful when you're drilling
the holes to screw the belts into he'll
Sparkle with glitter and glue
high-heeled-shoes can look absolutely
stunning but everyone knows who owns a
pair knows of the risk not to mention
the cost of them getting damaged but it
would be a terrible shame to have to
throw away a lovely pair of shoes
especially if you could fix them and
make them as good as new
or even better than new that's what one
smart and talented woman did to her old
pair rather than throwed them out when
the heels got damaged she decided to
Sparkle them up using nothing more
expensive than some glue and some
glitter she got them back up to scratch
she mixed the glue with the glitter to
make a thick paste then she applied it
to the damaged part of the shoe once she
had done that a couple of times and left
it to dry her once seemingly broken and
scuffed shoes were beautiful sparkly and
even more glamorous than when she first
got them damaged car saved by art a car
is every owners pride and joy it's one
of the most useful things you can buy
but it's also one of the most expensive
and when you have to get patrol and have
it serviced the cost can really add up
so what to do with another vehicle
scrapes against your motor
with unsightly scratches dents and cuts
most people would be tempted to cut
their losses scrap it and get a new one
but one Russian guy had a different idea
his car looked awful after a truck
scraped up against it
he took a permanent marker pen and
created an awesome work of art a map
with the dent caused by the collision
transformed into a breathtaking lake and
there was some good news the lorry
driver paid for the man to get his car
fix if that car was ours maybe we'd have
kept the beautiful work of art vases
fixed with golden thread a vase is
something that can be both useful and
beautiful if you'd like to keep flowers
indoors there's nothing better and the
lovely design can draw attention to your
plants but most spaces are made of China
and China breaks however there is one
genius artist who makes things even more
beautiful than they were before
Charlotte Bailey of Brighton England
uses an ancient Japanese art called kit
sugi to help repair her vases Charlotte
wraps the broken pieces in fabric before
using upstanding gold metallic thread to
sew them back into place again however
it's not something if you're looking for
a quick fix for a broken item the
smaller works in her collection took as
long as five hours to do while the
repairs for a larger piece can take
several days but looking at these
beautiful works of art you'd have to say
it was worth it
save broken mug handle with clay whether
you prefer coffee tea or hot chocolate
the chances are that you drink them from
a mug but what happens if the handle
gets broken on one of your favorite
drinking vessels rather than throw it
out you could do what one artistic and
creative person did and make it a new
more interesting sort of handle using
some polymer clay
they didn't just cover the bits of the
handle that were missing they improved
it - in this example what had previously
been a plain red mug became something
far more seasonal and festive with the
polymer painted and molded into the
style of a sprig of Holly but there are
lots of other ideas that could work too
so in some ways getting damaged was the
very best thing that could have happened
to the mug we wonder what sort of design
you'd have for your brand new handle
make a broken cellphone color
one of the most exciting and cool pieces
of technology we have is the smartphone
the whole world is at your fingertips
and in your pocket pretty cool yeah but
what happens if you drop the phone and
your back gets damaged it can be kind of
expensive
not to mention horrific ly inconvenient
to go and get it repaired or even
replaced well someone had the same
problem and came up with a totally
ingenious way to save his phone he used
a highlighter pen to draw all over the
back then he rubbed the excess ink off
with a paper towel the ink stays in the
cracks but manages to rub off the rest
of the back then to make sure that he
didn't get his fingers cut by the glass
he covered it with a piece of clear
packing tape the end result was a
vibrant funky and cool-looking mobile
phone that would certainly have turned
the head of anyone who saw it what
colors would you use tell us in the
comments and that's it 4:15 genius
people who fix broken stuff instead of
throwing it away if you liked this why
not check out ten hot glue gun life
hacks for crafting make sure you
subscribe to us for more videos like it
and thanks for watching
[Music]